Hey guys, I'm Nate welcome back to the kitchen where today
We are going to be boiling two different liquids to see what happens to them
I really don't know what's going to happen especially with the milk
I've seen the result of boiling down some soda it turns into this black
Goopy sludge that is mostly melted sugar with whatever other additives are inside some coca-cola, but milk
I don't know
I know there is condensed milk
And I don't know if that's just the same thing as boiling out some of the water
If there's anything added to that or taken away from it
and I'm also curious if boiling milk down until it's more of a
Sludge or even something dry and hard is part of the steps moving toward
Extracting the lactose from the milk. Lactose is one of the ingredients that we use when we make our
Homemade smoke powder and so I think it would be interesting if we can move toward getting all of those ingredients
From their original sources rather than just buying them from a chemical company
Let's take both of these liquids pour them into the pot
Throw them on the stove and see what happens if we boil away all of the water
Mmm, warm Cola, delicious
They say not to drink out of the carton, but no one else is gonna drink out of this, so it's only my germs
Both of these have
quite a bit of liquid in them and it's gonna take a long time for them to really heat up all the way so let's
give these, I don't know probably 15 minutes and start getting hot the plan is, once they both get to a
rolling boil I will turn the heat down to something more of a simmer because I don't want either of them to boil over and
I don't want either of them to burn as the liquid evaporates
Despite wanting to prevent any boil-overs by lowering the temperature
the milk still decided to expand in volume quite a bit and
Just boiled right over the sides of the pot. The soda really seems to be evaporating a lot faster than the milk
I'm not sure if the difference is just caused by the amount of heat or the different amount of surface area in the two different
Pots but the soda level has dropped considerably while the level of the milk seems like it's only gone down a little bit so far
The milk really likes to develop a skin on the top if it's not constantly being stirred
I don't know if that prevents it from losing any moisture at all, but it is interesting to watch it happen
There's also quite a buildup of
Milk residue on the side of the pot that it's heating up in... gross.
Our coca-cola has started to cook to a point that it can no longer really be described as coca-cola
Just a couple of minutes ago if I pass the spatula through it
You are able to see the white bottom of this pot
Now when I try and pass the spatula through it it seems that it's been stained dark brown or black
whatever this substance is it's very foamy and
Lightweight and smells very little like coca-cola. I leaned over the pot and some of the steam got in my eyes
And that was very uncomfortable. Might be smoke more than steam at this point
I don't know if there's any liquid left in here burnt sienna colour paint almost
That looks like tar
Gross, hope this pot isn't ruined forever. It's a nice pot. Well here is what happens with our coca-cola
It is burned it is black
It is
Disgusting. it does not smell like coca-cola
The steam or smoke or whatever it is that's rising off of it is very painful if it gets in your eyes
Barely liquid. It's interesting how it keeps bubbling, like I flatten it down and just kind of
Re-inflates itself and I don't know where that's coming from I really don't think there's any carbon dioxide
left in this from the carbonation of the soda
But something keeps making it kind of inflate back up as it stays hot
I've I've run out of space to stretch. This is going over three feet
Maybe about four feet going from the pot up to the spatula which is touching the ceiling
As these cool off they get more brittle there you go. There's your there's your coca-cola right there. Just shards of crystalline
something
All right, let's see what this tastes like
That's just pure burned burned. It's just carbon. Ah oh that's bad
Don't eat that guys don't don't boil coca-cola down until it's a burn disgusting mess and then eat it
You'll regret it
Our milk is still boiling away on the stove because it has a tendency to boil over if the heat is really high
We've had to keep it on much lower heat, so it is taking quite a while to evaporate
our milk has now been boiling for quite a while several hours in fact and it's gotten to a point where the
consistency and color have definitely changed
some of the color
Maybe because at times this has started to burn and we're getting a little bit of burned milk color in here
There's also a few little chunks of what I think have been the milk has it
Dehydrated on the side of the pot and then fell into the mixture if I scrape the spatula along the bottom
You can see what looks like
Just this weird
series of bubbles formed and
Anyone who has trypophobia is probably just gonna hate to look at that because it looks gross. I'll be honest
It's just really nasty looking. It smells bad. It doesn't smell like milk at all
It just it's just an indistinct something is burning smell
And I don't know if it's curdled or if that's just the bits that formed a skin on the top
And then I kept mixing them in and now there's not enough liquid for it to re-dissolve back in there
It's a lot thicker on the bottom than I thought it was too
I thought it was just like a super thin layer, but pretty thick
Layer and the bottom of it is just black already
I may someday want to try a different approach to this and instead of boiling off the water from the milk
just putting it in a dehydrator and letting that run for a day or
Several days until we've had all of the moisture leave the milk
But without the danger of burning or scalding it as we do so it's a sauce territory now
We've left
The drink category in and now deep into sauces and not good sauces either
I don't really want to but I feel like I have a duty to taste this stuff
Normally, I love milk. I'm not eager about this at all
(Mmm. Uh-uh.) I don't know how to describe that taste it doesn't taste like milk
It's not as pure burned flavor as the completely burned up coca-cola
Well, there's a little bit of the cheese flavor to it not like a lot
But a little bit of something it tastes kind of like cheese
But then mixed with burn not like the good kind of burnt cheese where you like fry it
And it gets a little bit crispy and that's really good. That's not this at this point. I'm probably gonna call this
I don't really want to keep going or I think I'll just do nothing but fill the kitchen with smoke
And it's gonna smell even worse that was milk. That was half a gallon of milk. I started out today wondering
What would happen if we boiled away all of the water in some coca-cola and some milk and the result for both of them is
very different
But they are both pretty gross it turns out drinks need to have their liquid in them
The coca-cola turned into a dark bubbly syrup, and then by pulling it out as it was kind of burning
We got these long fibrous strands that just sort of shatter into dust and then the milk turned into this
Orangey Brownish looking disgusting goop that I wouldn't really know how to describe that it's just like
Like if you blended up some meat and vegetables together, maybe just looks kind of like a vomit I guess hey, that's Pleasant
Hey guys. Thanks for watching if you're not a subscriber yet
Just hit the bomb to get in the club if you missed our last video or want to watch it again
Just click up here at the top click down there if you want to see what the internet thinks that you should watch next
That's it for now. Have fun. Be safe and see you tomorrow